my issue is this far left woke agenda  that has taken hold they are  when you start talking about when the  new york times runs  81 articles i think on gender neutral  bathrooms  when the world's on fire and this was  back when i think it was a couple years  ago it's like you're so out of touch  with how americans think you're so out  of touch when trans rights are trumping  everything else dude you're talking  about a very tiny tiny minority of  people  that when when you want to take children  and put them on puberty blockers  because you're an expert in in gender  dysphoria i don't  know you're not no you're not and i  don't agree let a child's brain develop  they go through phases you know